their windows are still full of
properties but agencies have had to
close shop and now the government's
effectively put the housing market into
the deep freeze
the director of this estate agents in
Southampton Tim Duggan says it's hard to
know what to expect next it's having a
huge impact we are still getting
inquiries in about properties which
we're just emailing back and saying
we'll look at it again in three weeks
when the restrictions been lifted we can
show you properties we are trying video
viewings but people still like to get in
and see the property before they'll make
a decision on whether they want to buy
it or if they want to learn what is
happening to the housing market is
unprecedented estate agents with decades
of experience are telling me they've
never seen anything like this before
the coronavirus has affected every
aspect of the market for instance on the
most basic level you can't show a
property and even if you could buyers
can't come and visit because of social
distancing rules and at this stage
nobody knows when that's going to change
many lenders have also now suspended new
mortgage applications but those who are
moving house should be able to extend
their mortgage offer for up to three
months enabling them to move in spring
or summer if the situation improves some
exceptions will be made
moving house will be permitted if it's
critically important or if the property
being moved into is currently empty
those who do go ahead though must
continue to respect social distancing
rules we have talked to the the more
lenders and we have agreed that they
would look to extend those mortgages to
a point at which completion can take
place we're also talking to the
conveyancing sector to make sure that
practically completion dates can be
moved forward Clem and Elaine Mason who
are in their 70s put their house on the
market in January and were hoping for a
quick sale but they're now resigned to
staying put for the moment well you
can't go around other people's
properties looking at them really can
you and you can't have people coming
around here
I know there are ways of doing it
virtually but it's not quite the same
and with so many people with problems on
losing jobs or losing income you know
who's going to be buying at this time
with some of the brexit uncertainty over
estate agents had hoped for a boom in
sales not anymore and with much of the
economy shut down it's feared it could
be more than a year before the housing
market returns to normal
Alex Rossi Sky News Southampton